the fbi is using cell phone data and
videos taken from
inside the capitol to find and charge
those responsible
for the deadly attack it's also trying
to determine
what the larger goals of the assault
might have been at least 13 people of
the nearly four dozen arrested are
facing federal charges
and disturbing new images of the siege
are now coming to light
jeff the gates has that part of our
story
[Applause]
new video showing the beginning
middle and end of the attack on the cap
[Music]
it had police grossly outnumbered
and running out of options capitol
police officers step aside
leading up to the shooting of one of the
rioters ashley babbitt
every image providing leads for
investigators
arrested richard barnett who was
gleefully posing for photos with his
feet on nancy pelosi's desk
and later showing off an envelope from
pelosi's office
he was charged with violent entry and
theft
also arrested west virginia lawmaker
derrick evans
videotaped leading some of the mobs
breaking into the capitol
the attack led to the deaths of five
people
including capitol police officer brian
siknik
flags have been lowered at half staff a
figure of historical
proportion and quite frankly those
capital police officers
really deserved a much better uh
planning and
response from their own leadership cadre
and it's just a
it's a black eye on all of us as
americans
the threat to washington may not be over
in the mob storming the capitol
investigators say there were armed white
supremacists and anti-government
militias
there are celebrations online according
to the anti-defamation league
some of the posts include threats to the
inauguration
trump will be sworn in for a second term
on january 20th
round two on january 20th this time no
mercy
i'm going and i'll be armed this time
this wasn't a riot it was an attack
this wasn't spontaneous it was
coordinated
and we need to now reckon with the
consequences for cbs this morning
saturday
i'm jeff begay is in washington